hey everybody and welcome back to the
ski resort I'm afraid I can't really
respond to comments and feedback on the
last video because I'm recording these
videos back-to-back because at the
moment that this video is coming out
I'll be traveling around Germany so
don't have a lot of time there to make
videos
fortunately unpop I should really
annunciate here unfortunately I didn't
have too much time also to record many
videos before that so yeah this whole
ski resort deal is really the only thing
I can bring out right now and the only
thing that I really wanted to work on
before I left so yeah this is what we're
stuck with today I'm gonna be working on
a gondola which is going to be the
largest ski lifts if the resort's and
I'll be building it on this separate
hill here but this will also really make
up the bulk of the resort as well I
don't want to make a really large resort
this will just be a small one with a few
lifts to get the general gist of a ski
resort out there and you know experiment
a bit with the different things that
come to making a ski resort so I want to
have a chairlift and a gondola and
restaurants and all kinds of other
facilities but really I don't want to go
too far with it because at some point it
also all just kind of becomes the same
and I don't want to do the same thing
over and over again so for now I'm just
shaping out the mountain trying to make
it as smooth as possible which again is
quite difficult having these very small
brushes so something that I ended up
doing mostly was using the flatten to
certain terrain to I'm not exactly sure
of what it was called again but I used
that to shape up the general shape of
the mountain and then using the raise
and lower terrain tools to soften the
edges of that and after that just
basically keep raising and lowering
certain patches of terrain whenever
there was a bump or a little hole until
it was more or less as smooth as
possible and after that just take the
smooth function make it as big as strong
as possible
and go over all of the terraforming as
long as you can until it all looks
smooth enough you might actually notice
me like over here changing the time of
day and I basically just did this to
check the shadows and make the the bumps
and the holes a little bit more
noticeable because it can be quite hard
to notice especially with the snow
texture being as White's and you know
very simple as it is it can be very
difficult to notice the the different
shapes of the terraforming so sometimes
changing the time of day can really help
with terraforming there eventually I
felt it was smooth enough so at this
point I started actually building the
gondola and very typically you'll find
that gondolas are some of the longest
ski lifts and as far as well my personal
reasoning behind this goes is that it's
probably because when you get into a
gondola as a skier at the very least you
need to take off your skis and put them
somewhere on the outside or the inside
of the gondola depending on what kind of
model it is whereas with the chairlift
you can just step in there and sit on a
chair and keep your skis which is a
quite a significant difference because
it means that getting into a gondola and
getting out of it takes a bit of time
you need to get off your skis and once
you're at the top of the gondola you
need to get on them again it can
sometimes be a bit of a hassle whereas a
chairlift you just get in and get out
with no hassle whatsoever of course
there are other people on the slopes as
well snowboarders I think of quite an
easier time with gondolas actually
because chair lifts really aren't made
for snowboarders so getting a snowboard
to fit comfortably on a chairlift
especially when it's one of those topple
mire Skippy chair lifts apparently I
think that's what they're called
sometimes you have these chair lifts
which don't have the supports for your
feet underneath the chairs and this is
something I think you'll mostly find at
10:00 or 8:00
chairlifts and especially on easy
beginner slopes but it's something so
there are definitely advantages and
disadvantages to using different kind of
ski lifts for a lot of people though the
worst are absolutely absolutely the
t-bar the ski lifts that's definitely
the case for me I was always really bad
at even going in them and trying to stay
upright because in these kinds of lifts
you actually stay on the ground with
your feet and something drags you along
which typically it's he bar but there
are some other shapes and variations of
this design as well but yeah those are
absolutely annoying I'm not a really big
fan but many of them are also a bit
older and you'll typically see them
being replaced by chair lifts or gone
the lows nowadays in any case the whole
idea behind this rent was that I chose
to have a gondola here because this is
the longest stretch of any ski lift in
the area and I wanted to have a gondola
here not to mention that they do add a
bit of comfort as well especially when
it's really cold
then gondolas are a bit more comfy you
can actually sit down and take off your
well your clothes not all of them of
course but you know wind down for a
little bit whereas in a chairlift you'll
still be exposed to the elements and I
do remember quite a few times if it was
especially cold in a chairlift you're
basically sitting there in the middle of
the the freezing wind and in a gondola
you're a bit more sheltered so there are
just ups and downs to everything but
yeah I basically just added all of the
details to the gondola again like the
extra frames the letters and all of that
stuff I finally decided to paint the
gondola cabins blue which is a color
that I personally like although I do
think that the devs made a good decision
in making the standard color of the
cabins red because I think you'll find
most of the CWA cabins in real life are
read at least nowadays and I do think it
looks really cool it's just something
about red being the default colour that
I wanted to try and go for it
color here now the thing also about this
this mountain in general is that it's
quite far away from the other hill that
I've made but it's not much taller so
the slopes on this will would be a lot
more gentle which is quite a good thing
I think in general I wanted to have the
sort of balance where about half of the
piece --ts are blue so beginner and then
half of that are well or a golden ratio
even it's then a little bit less are the
intermediate or red piste and then the
smallest group are the black piece so
it's kind of like 50% blue 30% red 20%
black something like that or maybe even
less black in any case I think generally
speaking you want to have majority of
blue and red slopes and then just a few
for those experts and there was
thrill-seekers that want to go out of
their way and go to the steepest hills
so that's why I thought it would be a
good balancing act to have this very
gentle hero here to also provide a
generous area where all of the beginners
can ski and not to mention of course the
ski resorts wouldn't really be
functioning too well if there wasn't
some kind of school and realistically do
you need some feasts which are very
accessible to schools and where kids can
learn to ski as well and generally
speaking also very much an upwards curve
to go along with the learning curve so
some very small and very gentle pastes
and then some slightly steeper longer
ones etc so you can build up gradually
and it doesn't just go from very easy to
very hard at any points so yeah that's
basically I'm shaping out these
mountains to get the shapes that I want
and to get the ink lines that I want
from the piste so it's just a bit
unnatural usually of course the ski
resorts aren't designed with the slopes
of the mountains in mind you just kind
of have to work with what nature gives
you but in this case I do have the
being able to choose you know how I
think things should go but at the same
time I don't want to take it too far of
course I do want things to look a bit
natural so I'm also trying to find a
balance between there as well
now I'm adding an extra lift here and
this all be the final of the the big ski
lifts I think I'll just be adding some
tea bars elsewhere for the beginners but
yeah and this is the only big lift I
would say that doesn't start from the
base camp that doesn't start from where
the town of the valley is going to be
and I think there's a there's a decent
point to having this here because it
more or less starts at the point where
this hill becomes a bit more steep up to
this point it's very gentle and we just
have that lower blue piece so at this
point we we finally get a more steep
section all the way to the peak of this
hill so I think having a chairlift here
fits quite well it also means that you
can ski from the other hill to this hill
without having to go down all the way
again so it's kind of bridging the gap
between these hills as well so all
together I think it's a decent
combination between these areas I think
it's also really interesting always to
see what kind of strategies go into the
placements of ski lifts in real life
because realistically you want to be
able to serve the largest amount of
feasts with the smallest amount of ski
lifts while at the same time also being
able to fulfill the capacity because if
it gets too busy you might also get
lines although especially with modern
day ten seater gondolas an 8 seater
chairlifts that's not as much the case
anymore but still is there's always a
lot of strategy involved in choosing the
right locations for where ski lifts
should stop and where they should start
and stop and there's also kind of a
public transport kind of thing to it
where you have to build a network where
you can make different connections
because obviously the ski lifts only go
up and skiers
only go down so being able to create
connections between different parts of
ski regions is always quite a difficult
task I think especially as soon as the
regions start becoming really big so I
always have a lot of respect for how
these things are planned outs and how
they make different connections and
sometimes even they don't really lead
the slopes at all there are a lot of ski
lifts which just connect different peaks
with no actual piece underneath them or
anything but they just would cross any
kind of natural barrier we're having
piste wouldn't really make sense or
wouldn't really be feasible so there's a
lot of intricacies to it anyway I want
to really catch up here because this is
something that I'm really excited about
and that I put in the thumbnail and
title of this video and the fact that
it's been taking ten minutes to get here
I think it's a bit misleading so I'm
sorry about that but I was just really
happy with how this turned out so I
wanted to make this the focus of the
video basically I talked about this
station design called the uni G from
Dover Meyer in the last video which to
me at least is very iconic it's probably
the most common station design it's the
one that they've used for a few decades
up till now although in more recent
years they've replaced it with a D line
pretty much but it's just I don't know
for me it's so iconic and for me there's
been a lot of childhood message memories
related to this thing and I just really
like the design of this it's a round
kind of cover over the station building
and I actually found this really
interesting websites and I'll link this
down in the description I suppose where
a company was talking about the product
design of making this station and what I
thought was a really interesting
approach to it is kind of what I've
alluded to in the first episode the way
that they were looking at this you know
until then the stations were often some
kind of how
some kind of building and the logic of
the designers was supposedly that you
know a ski-lift students look like a
restaurant or a hotel or shouldn't make
you think that it's that kind of
building and really the the building
that houses the technical aspects of the
lift should look like a machine because
that's basically what it what it is and
so that's how they ended up at the
design and at the shape of this this
station that they that they have it
really kind of looks like a machine and
it's very technological looking and kind
of futuristic so yeah that's why I
really like it I like the sleek glass
curves on the side and the window in the
middle which can open which honestly
looks pretty cool so that's basically
what I've pretty much recreated at this
point and it's not a lot I can say about
that really I didn't really put much
thought in this station I was just
trying to recreate as faithfully as I
could the uni G station design from
Joppa Meyer
there's also another design I think it's
called the Uni GV which looks a bit
different and I have to be honest unless
of a fan of that one in a it's different
on the side but it's not hugely
different and you'll find a lot of those
as well but I just really liked the
simplicity and how sleek this design
looks and I think it's also pretty
timeless some of them are getting
upwards of two decades old at this point
I think but they still usually look
brand new maybe not quite two decades
but they're definitely getting up there
so I also decided to go for the standard
color scheme basically or what I kind of
feel is the default color scheme you can
find these station covers in many
different colors but for me the the
white walls with the blue glass just
looks really cool and I've layered many
different layers of glass over each
other to achieve this blue look because
Glosson planet coaster is actually quite
transparent but you can get very
saturated colors if you layer
a lot of glass window panes on top of
each other so I think that works very
well and I'm actually just gonna copy
their station over for the chairlift I
was just getting really lazy at this
point and wanted to get it over with
but on the other hand I do think it fits
quite well and you do actually find a
lot of ski resorts where they have the
same kind of station designs for a lot
of the ski lifts especially if they've
invested in these ski lifts around the
same time but yeah that's that's
definitely interesting because there are
so many manufacturers and manufacturers
of different designs throughout the
years as well so going to the average
ski resort you'll find a lot of
different designs for stations and even
the the cars etc as well I've mentioned
for instance that these are all double
meyer chair lifts and gondolas that have
built so far but there's also two other
companies although you could kind of see
them sort of as one as well Lightner and
Poma which are both owned by the same
company but generally they look very
similar but yeah these these two are
basically the two biggest manufacturers
in the ski lifts industry I would say
topo Meier
versus Lightner Poma although dopa Meier
is technically also called the top
American event because they also merged
at some point so yeah technically
speaking I think the biggest ski lift
manufacturers are dope America Ravenna
and Lightner and Puma which really makes
it kind of a duopoly because these are
really just about the only competitors
for each other I think there are
definitely a lot of other manufacturers
and I do have a very Eurocentric view on
this because in Japan for instance
you'll find a lot of ski lifts made by
Nippon cable and there are just
different manufacturers also in
different areas of the world but
especially in Europe and America I think
these two companies pretty much rule
everything nowadays
but you can quite easily tell the
gondolas from Lightner or Poma apart
from each other because they both use
different cabins their cabins are a bit
edgier they don't have this rounded look
on the side as the cabins of CWA if topo
my Caravan to do and that we have in
planet coaster I believe that the Skyway
in Alton Towers is a light neuroma
because that has the same kind of
gondola design so that's just one of the
the things where you can recognize the
differences between manufacturers also
in the stations you won't find a unique
G station so this kind of station as I
have here on the lightener Poma gondolas
of chairlifts as well so there are just
all these differences it's interesting
to consider how he got to this point
though because it used to be the case
that there were many different
manufacturers and I think for a lot of
it it was just acquisitions of Lightner
or of Palma by Lightner for instance but
also apparently the Oppo Meier has
pretty much merged with everything ever
and acquired all kinds of smaller
smaller companies so eventually we just
ended up in a situation where these two
are leading and among the biggest
enthusiasts there's probably also always
the question of which one is better
personally I find the look of the dopa
my are ski lifts nicer but this is just
a completely subjective thing and I know
there are quite a few people who like
light neuroma lifts as well but when it
comes to comforts I think nowadays
they're both just really comfortable
many of the new lifts are all detached
which means that they're all really fast
and very comfy with soft seats and
sometimes even heated seats nowadays
which home if you ask me is a bit too
much almost I I don't know I'm not
entirely sure how I feel about the
heated seat unless it's really cold then
it's quite nice but if it's already a
sunny day and it's like if you
above zero I'm not sure how much I like
sitting down on a warm chair not to
mention just I don't know the the
general implication of sitting down
somewhere and feeling that it's warm
it's just something unnerving about it
but yeah technology keeps getting better
and much more interesting and I should
really give a shout out to the YouTube
channel of dopple Maya at this point
because they do have a YouTube channel
and it's pretty much just the business
advertisements and all kinds of product
reels but I think it's really
interesting and if you're interested in
the technology you can find some really
interesting clips there so I'll link
that down in the description as well
it's pretty cool to check out and every
now and then I just find myself going
back there to see what they're doing
especially kind of the urbanist in me
because there's also kind of a rising
discussion about using cable ways as
public transport networks which has been
done quite a few times in South America
now and it's really interesting
developments and it's really cool to see
how it can overcome some of the
challenges that other public transport
options can't really meet but yeah that
is going way of topic at this point I've
basically shaped out all of the the
priests of this area we have this very
wide area which is going to be the blue
slope very gentle very wide giving a lot
of space to probably the the most busy
piece of the area because everybody will
be able to ski beginner piste but only
the experts will be able to ski on the
advanced ones so I do want to make sure
that the beginner feasts are very wide
and have the largest capacity and then
on the side we just have a red one with
the chairlift on the side as well so for
those people were into that they can
stick to that section but this is also
actually the largest piece that you can
ski and the largest run that you can do
without having to go back up a lift and
I think it's quite important to have one
area where you can just keep skiing from
top to bottom without having to hit a
single lifts and for me personally I
always like being
able to cover very large distances
before you need to take off your skis or
get up into a chairlift again anyway
that'll be it for this episode thank you
guys for watching and I hope these guys
in the next episode in which I'll be
building some some of those terrible
skilift so I'm not a huge fan of but I
think we'll need anyway for realism sake
and also I'll be adding a bit more
detail to the lifts that have worked on
in this episode and maybe even start on
some simple restaurants or something
like that
we'll see anyway bye guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]